hi I'm Donna Oh that is the perfect name
for you I love it never change it wasn't
gonna your Craig right oh yes I hate
that name so boring it's not like
someone's cousin Craig Craig want to be
a Spanish man named Terrence but that
didn't happen okay so here's my list of
duties I'm basically the office manager
how about you oh I get everything
everything I carried the Eagleton
Department on my shoulders for years and
I loved every second of it you don't
even know I'm sorry was your name
Jennifer
no it's tenifer with two y's it used to
be Jennifer but then I decided to
rebrand myself oh wait hang on it's an X
o'clock um
well nice to meet you my name is April
and I just wanted to say that your dress
is so cute it's bongs it's on my
spinning instructor wearing it and I was
like shut up where do I get that oh my
god who's your spinning instructor
Gregory or Winona I go to Yanis who are
Gregory and Winona I've never heard of
them before are they better Winona
rocks my world seriously you need to get
me in there like that's a must must must
she's the worst person I've ever met I
want to travel the world with her you
have to sorry for the delay
ladies I was busy being ambushed by
treachery so did you have a chance to
compare notes on your respective duties
totally tinny and I have been like
totally bonding we've just been like
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah like
talking like so much forever is also
delicious I know right hey the best day
ever
I know I'm eating it all up wow it's
nice to see a friendship blossoming
instead of wilting away like a dying
turd flower totes um we also came up
with these nicknames for each other
[ __ ] and skank
how crazy mazing is that last well you
know what I think is crazy basing it I'm
looking for someone who's in it for the
long haul we are basically creating a
new version of Pawnee and if Pawnee is
gonna commit to one of you you need to
commit to Pawnee tenifer do you have
kids
you know I've had
much rejuvenation that I don't think a
baby could get out of there if it tried
you know it nope
what are these contracts it's just a
little something that I drew up for all
the employees of the new town
basic boilerplate language fifty year
commitment blah blah blah I'm so sorry
honey but tinny and I won't sign
anything until we speak with our life
coach
when Eric saw this he smashed a bunch of
computers why are you doing this what's
the big deal I'm just trying to stop
time with legally binding friendship
contracts what part of that do you not
understand you have lost your mind I
think you need a spa day TLAs fine
you only have to work here until I'm dad
is that better can I just say something
I'm having so much fun right now oh my
god me too like so much fun can I just
say something yeah okay you don't want
this job seriously this place is the
pits it's like if you worked here you'd
be like oh and Leslie it would be like a
blah blah blah and he'd be like uh okay
can I say something right now I totally
think that you're right and I had been
thinking about going someplace warm
while my husband is in jail oh my god
can I just say something yes okay you
should totally say in my house in Miami
what I'm serious come by anytime just
let yourself in the gate kind of jams
sometimes but you can just jump it you
are so amazing right now
you're like skinny mother Theresa it's
Dwayne Wade's house I got his address
off the internet I really hope he's
there when she walks in and he throws a
basketball at her head
you